if you love to cross the spider verse
like I did but you need more Spider-Man
in your life check out these next two
things if you own a PS4 or PS5 then you
have to check out Spider-Man Miles
Morales from 2020 developed by Insomniac
games that's a great story where you
play as miles coming into his own
Spider-Man through next-gen Graphics
incredible gameplay the Spider-Man
comics can be overwhelming and it might
be tough to find where to start I
recommend getting on the marble
unlimited app jumping into the 2099
series to not only see more of Miguel
O'Hara but to also check out fun
characters from the Marvel Universe in
that world such as Daredevil the
Punisher and even the Hulk